Speaker 1: So there was this competing conference
to CPAC over the weekend called AfPak The
America First.
Yeah, the America First Political Action Conference.
It is a white nationalist, far right conference.
Overtly, as you could say.
Well, isn't CPAC sort of that CPAC is what's
crazy is CPAC is now a radicalized version
of what Republicans used to be.
AfPak is a radicalized CPAC.
And there were a whole bunch of different
white nationalist extremists at the rally
and or conference.
And Marjorie Taylor Greene was a headline
speaker at the event, and she was then rightly
criticized, saying, You went to what is almost
an out and out Nazi event.
It's a white nationalist event.
These are some of the absolute worst people
right now.
And she claims ignorance to all of it.
So let's take a look, she said.
I was there because I want to speak to young
people.
Let's listen.
Speaker 3: But I'm glad to talk to you about
this.
I do not know.
I've never heard him speak.
I've never seen a video.
I don't know what his views are, so I'm not
Unidentified: in line with anything that may
be controversial.
What I can tell you is I went to this event
last night to address a
Speaker 3: very large following because that
is a young.
It's a very young following and it's a generation
I'm extremely concerned about.
Unidentified: It's a white, excuse me, excuse
me, a minute, and I'll tell you exactly why
I when I went to talk to them about America
First policy and I talk to them about what
Speaker 1: it's interesting, she says she
doesn't know who Nick Fuentes is, and she
doesn't know anything about the white nationalist
leanings of he and the group.
But she knows that these are young people
and that there's a bunch of them and that
they care about America first and for for
having no idea who these people were.
You seem to know a lot about it.
I spoke here knowing it was a large group
of young people engaged in America First policy
controversies, white nationalism.
I don't know anything about that.
So I just wanted to speak to them to give
them my America.
First idea is absurd.
She then put out a written statement where
she said, I mean, look at that, look at this
self victimization.
The Pharisees in the Republican Party may
attack me for being willing to break barriers.
What a what a martyr, huh?
And speak to a lost generation of young people
who are desperate for love and leadership.
But I won't abandon these young men and women
because I believe we need to do better by
them.
I won't cancel others if the conservative
in the conservative movement, even if I find
some of their statements tasteless.
Marge, it's a white nationalist event.
I encourage them to seek wisdom and apologize
to those who have been hurt by the words or
as I've had to do.
Our faith calls for charity and forgiveness
and then she just goes completely insane.
I'll keep fighting against identity politics
and Marxism.
What Marxism are you fighting against?
I'll keep speaking out and speaking up.
Our nation is only capable of protecting sovereignty
and then pulling out this insane statement.
The atheist media demands no disavowal from
left wing politicians who hang out with jihadis
and abortionists, but they demand immediate
disavowal of any Republican willing to speak
to.
Twelve hundred people gathered to declare
that Christ is king and brand them and headlines
exclusively by their sins.
Just as a little sampling of what there was
at this AfPak event just before bringing on
Marjorie Taylor Greene, there was Nick Fuentes
saying that their secret sauce is young white
men.
And then everybody started chanting Putin,
Putin.
Speaker 2: And you want to know the secret
to borrow a phrase from a friend of mine,
our secret sauce here, it's these young white
man.
That's what we call the secret ingredient
America, and the world is forgotten about
them, but not us.
Speaker 1: I don't think anybody's forgotten
about young white men
Speaker 2: say about America, they say diversity
is our strength.
You know, and I look at China and I look at
Russia.
Who can we give a round of applause for?
Absolutely, absolutely, yeah.
Speaker 1: So then Marjorie Taylor Greene
spoke, and the rest is sort of history.
These are really dangerous movements and there's
levels, right?
There's concentric circles.
It's like, OK, you've got the entire right
wing like, well, all right.
Well, that's a pretty big range.
You've got absolute lunatic, murderous extremist,
and you've got people where I disagree with
them about what the top tax rate should be.
OK, all right.
But then you've got to find within that, you've
got the Trumps, the Trumpian.
And then you've got the CPAC Trumpian and
then you've got people like Marjorie Taylor
Greene and then you've got so there's these
concentric circles.
And unfortunately, it can all spread outward
and infect the entire movement.
And that's how you end up with more than half
believing Joe Biden didn't really win
the 2020 election.